the Joe Rogan experience well how about
dr. Phil right no here's what's weird
about humans and culture dr. Phil has
been on for ever right here's about
million guests one girl comes on she's
like catch me outside and she becomes a
multi-millionaire she's huge
she's famous she sells makeup she's got
a [ __ ] giant billboard on sunset I'm
gonna be honest with you I listened to
her rap album and it is good there you
go she's hypnotizing Tony South Park
made fun of her with Cartman doing that
and I was like yeah 15 years how long
ago was like it where he was a little
girl on South Park talking [ __ ] he's
like [ __ ] yeah I do what I whoa about it
yeah that is a long time ago not that
long ago I think she's only like 17 or
something now I don't think we were in
this studio when that was happening
cache me outside
I don't even know but I mean the South
Park thing was predated her by a couple
years had oh okay
so was the South Park thing based on
anyone in particular I think that he
just had a lot of great like that was a
typical show and she's all stiff stood
out in the middle of Twitter world and
then right isn't that weird though
wouldn't something just takes off like
that it's weird how memes take off yeah
like in things like that like what what
things really grab people catch me
outside everything you're gonna be huge
I do what I want oh my god a legend oh
legend show legend show down that shows
one of the greatest like entertainment
franchises whether it's sports music
films greatest franchise ever South Park
no doubt about it they get away with so
much because it's all cartoon so they
can have people get their head chopped
off they can get beat to death lose arms
squirt right of their armpits because
it's so not real looking like Canadians
their heads aren't even attached
[Laughter]
top your head just floats in the air
it's so crazy I'm that for Canadians
that says it's so funny but it's not
even that mean you know anybody but it's
so ridiculous as they differentiate like
they're not even human there's this
different thing their [ __ ] heads
aren't connected that's just so crazy
it's the best show ever and look at that
oh my god South Park continues to mock
China yeah I see me do you know they
removed South Park from China but see
like you can't trick them the way they
tricked the NBA
those guys have plenty of money they
don't need your money they're there to
make this wild ass show and so if you
give them a reason like oh you're gonna
take away the China money okay not gonna
stop those guys by cutting off some of
the money and they'll have almost
everything they almost 70 got there one
one there one away from literally
accomplishing you know yeah they've done
everything they've been around forever
they've put together a play that's a
musical they put together films
I mean Team America World Police is
still to this day one of my all-time
favorite comedies and then before that
the South Park movie and when the South
Park movie when the the devil was gay
for Saddam Hussein and like you see like
big fake it like was dicks you see his
dick yeah remember but because it was
like a cartoon you like allowed to see a
dick look this is crazy
you ever seen lemmiwinks the episode
lemmiwinks which ones that favorite of
all time it's one where mr. garrison
wants to get fired from his jobs that I
think they were just paying people or
something like that so he's trying to
get fired so he had missed he hired mr.
slave to come in and try to get him
fired by doing gay stuff like and then
because he found out he could sue the
school because if he gets fired for
being a gay guy or whatever so
eventually as mr. slave come in and
teach I'm pretty sure maybe I have this
mixed up it's been a long time but gayer
and gayer stuff happens and he's not
getting fired
eventually he has mr. slave shove a
gerbil up inside
and all of a sudden the whole thing
switches over for the most part and
comes back and forth but it becomes an
adventure of lemmiwinks he has to make
it out of the game an but he can't but
he can't go out of the gates have closed
off for the sphincter and there's all
these like things that happen throughout
this show it becomes an adventure piece
yeah because he has to go all the way up
to get out look he has a little he has a
little candle what is he standing into
look look what's in the rectum it's just
green fluid with bubbles and chunks
floating and and that's another thing
he's going by corpses of other gerbils
as I do the [ __ ] they've had misses mr.
garrison do is a perfect example of how
you could never do anything remotely
like this on a regular show how about
when he had a slot off with Britney
Spears and he stuffed her up his ass to
win the [ __ ] off he stuffs Britney
Spears up his ass he climbs on her head
and shoves down until she disappears in
his ass it's unbelievable look like oh
my god oh my god can you just pull up
the scene just so Toni and I can watch
it of the [ __ ] off your Sultan the
always Paris Hilton why he was Britney
Spears at the same time you know they've
done Britney speed with with Britney
Spears they did the whole what was it
that they kept trying to make her be
better or something and they end up they
want her to keep making albums even
though they're driving her crazy
and then by the end she shoots herself
in the head or something like that but
then they have her in the studio and she
can't even make noises with their mouth
she blew her head off basically okay the
[ __ ] challenge it was a season that was
15 years ago
it's just it's so important for comedy
to have a show like that out there that
just has no boundaries
there's and comm essential just is smart
enough as with all the silliness that
they've been accused of they're smart
enough to leave those guys the [ __ ]
alone mm-hmm just let them keep doing it
you know you've seen six days to air yes
great yeah do you remember when they had
Mohammed inside a bear costume inside a
van with the van door closed and people
are still mad do you remember that now
not exactly is that actually Mohammed I
did they went full oh no was this
recently yeah
Mohammed getting knocked down by Lincoln
no one takes it further than the Muslims
though like even draw our guy if you
even draw our guy death that's right he
was in a bear costume too if you even
draw our guy death
[Applause]